Russia has stepped up its rocket attacks
on Ukraine with fresh strikes on cities
across the country
authorities say Russian Rockets hit a
residential building in the capital Kiev
killing at least three people the
strikes knocked out power supply in the
western city of leviv and disrupted
water supply in several regions also in
neighboring Moldova officials say power
was lost to half of the country due to
the strikes in Ukraine
now this comes after Ukrainian officials
set a strike on a maternity ward in the
southern zaparisia region on Tuesday
killed a newborn baby
pulled from the rubble of what was a
Maternity Ward this doctor was fortunate
to make it out alive
but the Russian strike that flattened
his workplace did take the life of the
baby he was there to deliver
its mother was rescued just the latest
casualties of yet another attack on a
healthcare facility
Moscow has long denied targeting
Hospitals and Clinics but the World
Health Organization has recorded more
than 700 attacks since the start of the
war nine months ago
Russia's repeated attacks on energy
infrastructure are making it harder for
doctors to provide Care at those
hospitals that are still standing
here in her song They're forced to work
by flashlight as they try to save a
teenager whose hand was blown off in a
Russian strike
without power for the elevator he has to
be carried up six flights of stairs on a
stretcher to reach an operating room lit
with only emergency lights
it's hard without an elevator hard
without light to get the child to the
sixth floor no water no Heating
working in the dim light doctors
amputate the teenager's left arm
his mother Waits nearby
inconsolable
they shoot at civilians at children we
didn't call them here and didn't kill
any of their children so why are they
killing ours
but with Russian attacks continuing and
winter beginning to bite hairson
residents are facing shortages of water
food and other Essentials
many are making a difficult choice
and joining the government's voluntary
evacuation effort
boarding buses to seek safety further
from the front lines
let's get across to DW's Nick Connelly
reporting from Kev Nicki give us more
details on these latest Russian strikes
across Ukraine
well these are genuinely on a massive
scale of the kind we've seen maybe two
three four times over the past month or
so uh dozens and dozens of cruise
missiles uh fired by Russian planes
towards Ukraine we've got a sense of it
early afternoon when those uh planes
those Russian planes were seen spotted
by Ukrainian forces and within a couple
hours those missiles started hitting
starting hitting their targets here in
Ukraine lots of the country without
power often enough without water because
obviously those Water Supplies are
dependent on electric pumps lots of
places without centralized heating we
had a heating plant here in Kiev that
was hit as we understand I think the
kind of situation here in Kiev is about
you know pretty representative is what
you can see behind me a lot of Darkness
a huge city of millions of people in
darkness but occasionally some street
lights some uh you know advertising is
often quite random and difficult to tell
why bits and City are still supplied
with electricity
um often you're you know you'll find
that your building is connected by a
line to a hospital or some other kind of
critical infrastructure and as such
still has power and you know lots of
people here still have the expectation
that this is one of these attacks that
will be overcome in the space of if not
a few hours than at least a few days
we've heard though that three of
Ukraine's major nuclear power stations
still in Ukrainian control territory
have automatically disconnected
themselves from the system as a security
precaution so a real sense there that
this is a very dangerous situation a
situation that can cause lots of
unforeseen effects on this country's
infrastructure and one that is
definitely going to take a lot of effort
to make good and especially a situation
where Ukraine is essentially running out
of spare parts to keep the system going
basically we've heard in recent days
that they are now 100 dependent on spare
parts coming in from abroad because
everything that Ukraine had that has
just now been used up
and Nick the neighboring country of
Moldova has also been reporting massive
blackouts after those missile attacks
what's behind that
so Moldova and Ukraine's energy systems
are very closely linked before this war
mordov imported electricity from Ukraine
Ukraine isn't doing that anymore in a
large scale it needs all the electricity
it can get but certainly lots of these
uh you know the the kind of electricity
cables the lines they are all connected
so when Ukraine switched things off to
kind of stabilize the system that
immediately impacts Moldova Moldova in
itself is in a big energy battle with
Russia with Russia's gas prom Monopoly
uh reducing deliveries of gas to Moldova
now ahead of winter uh
russian-controlled separatists in
Moldova cutting supplies to government
controlled territory so a real sense
that Russia is putting on all the screws
right now and at the same time as
invading Ukraine trying to get rid of a
pro-european government in kitchen now
in Moldova
DW's Nick Connelly reporting for us from
Keith many thanks as always
well I'm very pleased to welcome Anna
Newman in the studio with me now he's
the head of the Ukraine Mission at the
International Organization for migration
a very warm welcome thank you so much
for taking the time to speak with us
your organization is dealing with
millions of people who have been
displaced inside of Ukraine um can you
tell me about what their situation is
like facing a winter with these
widespread power outages yeah thanks for
having me yes exactly I mean we have
around 6.5 million
um internally displaced and the fear
that we have is the longer that the war
continues the the increase of their
vulnerabilities we have around 45
percent of of the of the idps reporting
that their homes have been damaged five
percent of those basically say that that
their homes are completely damaged we
have more than 250 000 that are sitting
in or or staying in Collective centers
one of the things that we're very
worried about is what we call negative
coping mechanisms that we see um being
displayed borrowing money spending Less
on Health Care alternating their their
their their source of eating and the the
biggest worry right now that we have is
the fact that more than 50 percent of
the idps have used up all of their
savings and so this is something that
that continues to worry because you know
the cost of heating the energy the cost
for them to stay where they are has
increased in such a way that they become
much much more vulnerable especially
during the winter time so these are
really serious Ripple effects we've had
heard some Ukrainian officials urging
displaced ukrainians not to return to
Ukraine in the coming months the head of
a Ukrainian power supplier even
suggested that civilians should leave
their homes for a few months in order to
reduce power supplies and demand on the
energy Network it sounds like in these
circumstances that you're describing
would you agree that that is something
that you would recommend for them to do
um I I wouldn't recommend as much as
saying that I think that that it's it's
uh people need to find alternatives for
more sustainable situations there are
people that have the ability to move to
their dachas for example one of the
things that we've also seen is as
Ukraine is becoming more developed
there's more urbanized populations and
they're so dependent on the central
heating as the reports have said I think
the Ukrainian population is much more
resilient than we see it there's much
more patience and so we haven't seen yet
this this flow moving outwards because I
think that that there's a sense of
solidarity for them to be able to to
stay in Ukraine and and stay in in their
their primary residence and even with
this tremendous resilience as you and I
speak today in this studio and we know
that Russian missiles are raining down
around Kiev do you think that Russia is
deliberately seeking to make life harder
for Ukrainian civilians
I can't speak to the approach that
Russian Federation has but I can speak
to the fact that the impacts are great
especially for the civilian population
since October 10th we've seen such an
increase in terms of attacks towards
infrastructure that has significantly
impacted not only the idps but all of
Ukraine we've all have been impacted
every single person in Ukraine has been
impacted by energy as has also been
impacted by by shortages sometimes of
running water and so it it is something
that is of big concern especially for
the humanitarian community in terms of
how do we take a look at responding to
the to those most vulnerable and those
who who really need as much help as we
can provide okay I want to thank you so
much for taking the time to speak with
me on DW news that's on Newen from the
International Organization for migration
thank you for having me appreciate it